Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Makujo-List mein Name.
Ich bin hier als Ersten Tätig und heute kümmere mich um Sie.
Ist das für Sie?
Das ist in Ordnung für mich.
Okay, gut.
Ich bräuchte eher Ihren persönlichen Draht.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Müller, Martin Müller.
Martin Müller.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
56, waren Sie in den Geboren?
Am 12. Mai 1968.
1968.
Wie schwer und wie groß Sie sind?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,65 groß und wiege circa 85 Kilogramm.
85 Kilogramm.
1,65 Meter.
Richtig, ganz genau.
Herr Müller, erzählen Sie mal, weshalb sind Sie hierhergekommen?
Ich habe Angst, dass ich einen Schlaganfall habe.
Ich habe in der letzten Zeit oft hübbeln in den Beinen
und kann manchmal Sachen nicht ganz genau fühlen.
Sie haben einen Schlaganfall?
Ich glaube, ich habe einen Schlaganfall.
Sie haben kribbelnde Beine und was noch?
Ich kann manchmal Sachen nicht gut fühlen in den Fingern.
Gibt es eine Taubheitsgefühl?
Richtig, ganz genau.
Seit wann leiden Sie darunter?
Schon über 3 Monaten.
Schon über 3 Monate?
Träten diese Beschwerden ab und zu auf?
Nein, die werden jetzt immer mehr.
Immer mehr?
Krribbelnde Beine und Taubheitsgefühl haben Sie?
Genau.
Beine und manchmal auch in den Fingern.
Wenn ich jetzt mein Hemd zuknüpfen möchte,
dann ist das schwer für mich.
Oder wenn ich meine Schuhe zubilden möchte,
dann kann ich das manchmal nicht gut fühlen.
Okay.
Taubheitsgefühl an den Finger und kribbelnde Beine.
Richtig?
Ja, auch Taubheitsgefühl in den Beinen.
Bis zu dem Knie hoch.
Bis zum Knie.
Im Oberschenkel haben Sie nichts?
Nein, ich habe nichts gespürt.
Bis zum Knie.
Bis zum Oberschenkel.
Nicht Oberschenkel.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Zum Beispiel Schmerzen?
Manchmal sticht das sehr stark.
Also ein piksendes Schmerzen.
Ein piksendes, stechendes Schmerzen.
Wo genau?
In den Füßen.
Und in den Unterschenkel.
Und wie stark sind diese Schmerzen?
Auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10.
1 bedeutet leichte Schmerzen
und 10 bedeutet starkste Schmerzen.
Also 4, 5 ungefähr.
Sind die Schmerzen immer da?
Die kommen ab und zu.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl, als wenn sie nachts vermehrt wären.
Nacht.
Schlafen Sie wegen Schmerzen schlecht?
Ich muss manchmal sogar aufmachen.
Gibt es etwas,
dass Ihre Schmerzen lehnt oder verbessert?
Nein.
Zum Beispiel, wenn Sie sich liegen
oder wenn Sie ins Bett gehen.
Sind die Schmerzen in der Nacht schlimmer?
Ich glaube schon.
Ich bin nicht ganz sicher.
Gibt es ein Auslöse vielleicht?
Was sehen Sie?
Ich wüsste nicht.
Sie sind seit über 3 Monaten.
Wie ernähren Sie sich Herr Müller?
Gut.
Haben Sie eine Essgewohnheit?
Sind Sie veganer?
Nein, ich erseh nicht alles.
Sie essen auch Fleisch.
Und Schmerzen?
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe sie nicht gemessen.
Ihnen üben?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Manchmal ja.
Seit wann?
Ich weiß nicht.
Haben Sie Atemnur?
Ich habe es nicht gemerkt.
Oder Herzrasen?
Ja, wenn ich mich anstrengere.
Wie oft treten diese Herzrasen auf?
Wenn ich mich anstrengere.
Wie sieht es denn aus?
Mit dem Wasser lassen?
Mit Wasser lassen habe ich keine Probleme.
Nein.
Ist die Apetit gut?
Ja.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Eigentlich nicht.
Ich bin schon über mehrere Jahre alt.
Ich habe es schon über 2,5 Kilogramm.
Ist die Apetit gut?
Sehr gut.
Ich bemerke es.
Alles gut.
Haben Sie Schlafprobleme?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Einschlafen?
Das kommt immer davon,
wie die Schmerzen in den Beinen sind.
Manchmal nicht.
Ich wache meistens auf oder kann ich einschlafen?
Beides.
Schmerzbedingte
Schlafstörung.
Mühlen Sie noch etwas hin?
Ich bin auch letztens gefallen.
Mein Nachbar hat vor kurzem einen Schlaganfall gehabt.
Er hat gesagt, er hat das Gleiche gehabt.
Deswegen bin ich sehr besorgt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir mal ein CT vom Kopf machen müssen.
Wir gucken auf die Schlafen.
Ich habe noch etwas zu tun.
Ich habe noch einen CT vom Kopf gemacht.
Sind Sie auf dem Kopf gefallen?
Nein.
Keine Kopfverletzung?
Worauf sind Sie gefallen?
Ich bin gestolpert.
auf dem Boden? Haben Sie Ihr Beutzeitsverloren? Nein. Nein. Sie waren auf dem Boden. Ich bin gefallen.
Aha. Okay. Haben Sie Ihr Gleichgewicht verloren oder nur wegen stolpern? Ja, Sie haben... Ich bin mir
nicht sicher, aber ich glaube, ich bin gestolpert, aber irgendwie ist der Boden weg gewesen. Ich habe
irgendwie gefallen und ich habe seitdem auch ein bisschen Gleichgewichtstörung habe ich das Gefühl.
Aha. Okay. Haben Sie eine Gangstörung zum Beispiel? Können Sie normal laufen? Ja.
Aber in der letzten Zeit? Unsicherer. Etwas unsicherer.
Aha. Können Sie zum Beispiel Treppe hochgehen? Ja. Okay. Haben Sie
Sie Probleme? Können Sie gut sehen? Ja, Alter sind sprechen. Also ich trage eine Brille, wenn ich lese.
Aha. Okay. Sie sehen ist in Ordnung. Hören, wie Sie testen mit dem Hören? Haben Sie Hörprobleme?
Ich denke, ich höre noch gut. Ja. Okay. Leiden Sie unter Kraftlosigkeit zum Beispiel? Ja,
so ein bisschen an den Beinen habe ich wenig Kraft. In der letzten Zeit? Okay. Sie haben vermehrt
stürzt. Oder können wir sagen? Ich bin nur einmal gestürzt. Nur einmal. Einmal. Okay. Aha. Ja. Ja. Wenn Sie möchten,
Sie etwas hinzufügen, haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, belegen Sie mal. Nee. Es ist etwas,
dass Sie mir sagen wollen. Ja, glauben Sie, dass auch ein starker Verlag ist? Ein Verlag.
Daranfall kann ich momentan nicht genau sagen. Erst müssen wir unser Gespräch zum Ende führen.
Ich muss Sie für völlig untersuchen und ich brauche noch einige Untersuchungen. Ja,
dann werden wir noch besprechen. Okay. Gibt es eine Geschmäckveränderung oder nur haben
Sie Kraftlosigkeit nur an den Beinen? Ja, nur den Beinen eigentlich. Okay. Gibt es in der
letzten Zeit einen Second Bis? Haben Sie bemerkt? Nein. Second Bis, ein Insex? Nein. Ich auch nicht. Nein.
Okay. Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland? Nein. Nein. Okay. Ja. Jetzt möchte ich zu Ihrer
Vorgeschichte übergehen. Gibt es Vorerkrankungen bei Ihnen zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit,
eine elbliche oder geistliche Krankheit? Ja, ich habe Bluthochdruck und Zucker habe ich auch.
Ja. Und ich habe ja Hüttenkolesterol. Seit wann? Ungefähr seit zehn Jahren. Alle sind seit zehn
Jahren. Ja, das kann so nach und nach. Gibt es noch andere Vorerkrankungen bei Ihnen?
Und Gott sei Dank nicht. Ja. Okay. Nehmen Sie dagegen Medikamente ein? Ja. Was nehmen Sie,
Herr Miller? Ich nehme Blutdruck Medikamente ein. Ja. Ich nehme Ranitril 5 Milligramm ein.
Und noch etwas? Und ich habe Medformin, nehme ich ein. Medformin, wie viel Milligramm?
1000 Milligramm, morgens und abends. Und wegen Ihrer erhöhten Kulesterinwerte, was nehmen Sie ein?
Atorvastatin. Wie viel Milligramm, Herr Miller? 40 Milligramm. Wie viele? 40 Milligramm.
Abends nehmen Sie ein, ja? Genau, richtig. Okay. Wo würden Sie schon einmal operieren,
Herr Miller? Ja, in meiner Jugend, mein Blinddamm ist raus. Wie alt waren Sie? Ich glaube, 16. 16.
Ist die Operation Komplikation losverlaufen? Ich vergesse. Ich war ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus.
Eine Woche war ich im Krankenhaus. Eine Woche ist schon ein bisschen fertig. Ja, das ist jetzt 40
Jahre her, ne? Ja, natürlich. Okay. Und Sie sind nur einmal operiert geworden, ja? Richtig.
Gut. Reagieren Sie allergisch auf Medikamente oder haben Sie eine Unverträglichkeit gegenüber
Lebensmittel? Nicht das, ich wusste, nein. Nein? Gut, raufeln Sie, Herr Miller? Ab und zu.
Ab und zu bedeutet, wie oft raufeln Sie? Wie viel? Also zwei, drei Mal in der Woche.
Haben Sie früher halt vielleicht mehr geraucht? Ja. Wie viel? Wie viel? Also ich habe bis vor fünf
Jahren jeden Tag eine Packung geraucht. Wie lange haben Sie geraucht? Ja, ich habe so mit 20 angefangen
und wahrscheinlich so 25 Jahre oder so, oder vielleicht länger. Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja. Was trinken Sie und wie oft trinken Sie Alkohol? Ja, jeden Tag Feierabier, auf jeden Fall.
Und am Wochenende kann es auch ein bisschen mehr sein. Was? Auch Bier? Auch Bier, manchmal auch Schnaps,
auch Wein. Eine reine Routinefrage, die ich aus medizinischen Gründen stellen muss.
Habt ihr noch Erfahrungen mit den Drogen? Ich habe bisher noch keine harten Drogen genommen.
Okay, sehr gut. Gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen, lebt Ihre Vater und Mutter noch?
Ja, mein Vater ist schon sehr früh gestorben, da war ich noch ein Kind und meine Mutter ist
tatsächlich an einem Schlaganfall gestorben. Wie alt war er denn Sie? Wie alt meine Mutter war?
Ja, in 70 Jahren gestorben. Ihre Mutter? Richtig. Und Ihr Vater, woran ist der gestorben?
Was weiß man nicht, er ist einfach umgefallen. Er war noch ein Kind. Wie alt war er?
Der war damals 41. Sehr jung, sehr plötzlich. Ja, und jetzt, was machen Sie bäberpflicht, Herr Müller?
Ich arbeite im Büro. Als Was? Als Sachbearbeiter.
Habt ihr viel Stress bei der Arbeit in der letzten Zeit? Ja, um zu tun.
Ja, Sie haben wahrscheinlich eine Sitzende-Tätigkeit, ja? Richtig.
Eine Bewegungsarm? Ja, ich stehe schon auf, hol den Kaffee und so.
Sind Sie feinheiratet? Geschieden.
Haben Sie Kinder? Ich habe einen Sohn. Ist er gesund?
Er ist gesund, ja. Gesund, ja.
Vielen Dank, Herr Müller. Jetzt bin ich fertig mit meinem Fragen. Vielen Dank für die ausführliche
Informationen. Jetzt werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen. Dann werde ich Blut abnehmen, um einige
Arameter zu beurteilen. Dann brauchen wir einige Untersuchungen, Bildgebände verfahren.
Und wenn alle befunden Kollegen, wenn wir sprechen, wie es weitergeht, haben Sie noch Fragen an mich.
Denken Sie, dass das ein Schlag an Frau sein könnte? Natürlich werden wir das untersuchen,
aber jetzt kann ich nicht etwas Genaures sagen. Ich möchte etwas Falsches sagen.
Wir sehen uns im Menigaminitum wieder.
Vielen Dank. Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Blutzucker gemessen?
Blutzucker? Nein. Ich habe eine Frage für Sie.
Haben Sie seit der letzten drei Monaten in der letzten 3 Monaten Pfermätwasser trinken oder Pfermätwasser lassen?
Wie immer.
Zweite Frage ist, haben Sie Muskelkrempfe oder Muskelsückungen?
Ja, ich denke schon, dass es nicht Schmerzen hat, die ich habe unterschränkt.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe noch andere aber.
Bitte schön. Haben Sie eine blasse Haut bemerkt? Nein.
Mir geht es zu weit gut. Ich habe nur diese Probleme mit den Beinen und ein bisschen an den Fingern manchmal.
Als Besuch, habt ihr gefragt? Nein, ich war jetzt auch schon über einem Jahr nicht beim Hausarzt gewesen.
Ich habe nur meine Medikamente verschreiben lassen, sonst nichts.
Haben Sie seit der letzten Zeit verletzt?
Gestisch geworden, ich denke nicht.
Die Schmerzen sind irgendwo hin?
Nein, die Strahlen sind nicht aus. Die sind in den Beinen, also von den Füßen bis zu den Knien ungefähr.
Da habe ich die Schmerzen und den Traubweitzgefühl.
Wenn ich meine Schuhe zubinde oder wenn ich meine Hälfte zu knöpfe habe, habe ich Schwierigkeiten, manchmal nicht immer, den Knopf zu halten und zu zu knöpfen.
Manchmal, manchmal, nicht immer. Aber er ist unsicher, wenn ich gehe, dann muss ich mich festhalten und ich bin ja auch schon mal gestürzt.
Wie sieht Ihre Schwierigkeiten aus?
Das kann ich nicht genau sagen, es ist wie, wenn ich so manchmal ins Leere trete, als wenn so ich keinen richtigen Stand habe.
Schutul und ürin hat gefragt?
Auch noch, wenn ich.
Ich denke, ich habe die Fragen gestartet. Könnt ihr mir als erstes gesprochen haben?
Sehr gerne.
Bitte schön.
Hallo, ich bin einen guten Tag. Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen, falls Sie kurz für mich Zeit haben.
Bitte schön, gerne.
Ja, der Patient heißt Martin Müller. Er ist 56 Jahre alt, 1 Meter, 65 groß und wie geht es zur Zeit? 85 kg.
Er kam heute zu uns seit 3 Monaten bestechender, bestechender Parästhesien in den Finger und an den Beinen und so wie Hippo-Esthesien.
Auslärm klackte er über stechende Schmerzen, die häufig in der Nacht, sowohl tagsüber als auch in der Nacht in den Füßen und in den Unterschenkel aufseten.
Der Patient erzählte, dass er gestern gestern gestützt habe und er erzählte, dass in den letzten Tagen unzieher, ihr Gang unzieher geworden sei.
Er berichtete über ein Astheny an den Beinen.
Ein Was?
Astheny, Astheny Kraftlosigkeit.
Okay.
Astheny an den Beinen.
Hat er gar keine Kraft mehr oder?
Ja, gar keine.
Kann er gehen?
Er kann gehen, aber er ist unwichtbar beim Laufen.
Er hat eine muskel-üchliche Recherche.
Astheny nicht, weil Astheny eine chronische Symptome ist.
Diese Symptome ist leicht, eine leichte Kraftverlust.
Ich denke schon.
Eine leichte Kraftverlust an den Beinen.
Kann man sagen.
Ja.
Okay.
Er sei seit über einem Jahr nicht bei Hausarzt gewesen.
Blutzucker habe in der nächsten Zeit nicht gemessen.
Die Frage nach Zäcken bis und Insektenstich wurden verneint.
Ein Moment.
Herr Hoijam, könnten Sie bitte eine Zusammenfassung?
Ja.
Der Patient berichtet seit drei Monaten über eine über zunehmende
Schmerzen in den Füßen bis zu den Knien.
So wie ein Paupaltsgefühl, Kribbelparastäsien an den Händen
und an den Füßen mit nächtlichen Schmerzen.
Und einem Schwindel und einem Sturz einmalig gestern.
Moskvilschwächer.
Danke schön. Bitte schön, Gülsha.
Okay.
Wir gehen jetzt an einem Näseergab, ein Schwindel,
eine Vertigo, eine Insomnie, so wie eine abhängige...
Kanägen nicht schlafen?
Aha.
Nein, eine Düstomnie.
Eine Düstomnie.
Eine Schmerzbedingte, Beschwerdebedingte Düstomnie.
Ja, an Vorerkrankungen seien den Patienten eine Artilie-Proponie,
eine Diabetes-Pros, eine Hyperpolastronomie,
seit zehn Jahren bekannt.
Der Patient wurde in einem Alter von 16 appendectomiert.
Und die Rollereiseanalyse war unauffällig.
Folgende Medikamente nehmen der Patient regelmäßig ein,
mit 15 mg morgens, mit Formen 1.000 mg morgens und abends,
Atomastatin 40 mg abends.
Herr Müller berichtete keine Allergie
und berichtete über keine Allergie.
Herr Müller rauchte bis seit Rave geregentlich Zigaretten,
rauf geregentlich 2-3 Mal pro Woche in den letzten 5 Jahren.
Davor habe er ca. 25 Jahre lang eine Packung Zigaretten geraucht.
Er trinkte abends Bier, am Wochenende trinkte er etwas mehr Bier,
Schnaps und Wein, Drogenkonsum, wo das einnahm.
Ihr Vater sei in einem Alter von 41, plötzlich verstorben.
Die Ursache ist nicht bekannt.
Die Mutter ist mit 70 Jahren an Apoplex verstorben.
Herr Müller, Sachbearbeiter von Beruf,
er hat seine Tätigkeit stressig und regungsarm.
Er sei geschirrt, habe eine gesunde Sonne.
Angesichts der an einem nächsten Angaben
vermute ich in diesem Bereich
ein unruhiges Beinsyndrom oder ein Vitamin B12-Mangel.
Differentialdiagnostisch kommen multiple Cycleros,
Magnesium-Mangel und eine Raumforderung im Rebellum.
Sie haben gesagt, dass er eine Diabetes hat.
Haben Sie gefragt, wann zuletzt der HB1C kontrolliert wurde?
Ich habe danach nicht gefragt.
Er trinkt auch Alkohol.
Wahrscheinlich ist er ein Alkoholiker.
Ich denke, wir sollten zuerst überlegen,
ob es sich daran liegen könnte.
Diabetes-Fuss-Syndrom?
Nein.
Diabetes-Neuropathie.
Genau.
Man muss überlegen, ob er eine Alkoholbedingte Neuropathie hat.
Das klingt nach Neuropathie.
Es könnte aber andere Erkrankungen sein.
Was gibt es noch, Differentialdiagnostisch?
Wo müssen Sie noch denken?
Vitamin B12-Mangel, zum Beispiel.
Es kann auch sein, dass er eine genetische Erkrankung hat.
Eine genetische Neuropathie.
Oder ein Gilian-Baris-Syndrom.
Ich denke, wir haben vorher Gedanken.
Kardiologisch?
Er ist ein Arterie-Petron, der die Diabetes-Mangel hat.
Die Familie ist eine genetische Anämne.
Die Alkohol-Anämne ist eine genetische Anämne.
Ich bin nicht ein Filmsyker.
Deswegen ist es erst mal,
dass man eine Kardiologische Diagnose hat.
Es kann sein, dass er eine PAVK hat.
Aber Kardiologisch oder Angiologisch?
Kardiologisch ist ein Oberberuf.
Welche Kardiologische?
Die Kardiologischen Artistenöse.
Machen die auch Symmetrische Neuropathie?
Eine lange Zeit.
Auch bei den Helmen?
Ja, beide.
Wenn ein Schlagkampf macht,
deswegen können die Hände und Beine zusammen.
Macht es auch Schmerzen?
Nein, keine Schmerzen.
Ich denke, wir sollten erst neu-logisch überlegen.
Kardiologisch, meiner Meinung nach.
Es könnte aber angelogisch sein, eine AVK.
Eine Gefäßerkrankung.
Es könnte auch gut sein.
Aber wo?
Auf welcher Höhe?
Welche?
Schwierig.
Er hat keine Probleme mit dem Gang.
Er kann lange Strecken gehen.
Er hat keine Kardikation.
Er kann normal gehen, sagt er.
Ich glaube eher, dass er eine Neuropathie hat.
Eine Symmetrische Neuropathie.
Die Frage ist, woran es liegt.
Berge, ihr weht es?
Ihr weht es?
Wir wissen nicht.
Er hat eine Hbac von 18-19.
Also es klingt nach Neuropathie, Vitamin B1-Mangel mit Alkohol oder Vitamin B12-Mangel oder Diabetes.
Ich würde ja vermuten, dass eine Diabetes-Polyneuropathie ist.
Aber wir müssen natürlich auch alles andere mit bedenken.
Und wie man, wie Hodja das auch sagt, ist richtig, man sollte kardiologisch, angiologisch auch schauen,
aber er scheint aktuell keine kardiologische Problematik zu haben.
Außer seinem Blutotruck.
Was man auch fragen kann bei der Neuropathie ist, wie die Haut ist.
Ist die Haut trocken, zum Beispiel.
Bei Neuropathien kann die Haut manchmal sehr trocken, sehr rausein.
Ob die Füße kalt sind oder ob die eher warm sind, das kann man natürlich auch fragen.
Was machen wir denn mit den Patienten? Welche Werte nehmen sie ab?
Und was haben sie vor?
Nehmen Sie den Patienten stationär auf, nehmen Sie gut ab, was machen Sie?
Ja, und Blutzucker würde ich natürlich messen.
Definitiv.
Und Hemoglobin A1c.
Definitiv, richtig.
Blutdruck und Vitalparameter werde ich kontrollieren.
Ist kolesterinwerte gut eingestellt, würde ich das überprüfen.
Bei den Hohlhörigen.
Ihren Werte sind wichtig.
Es kann auch eine Uremie vorlegen.
Uremische Neuropathie selten kann aber vorkommen.
Er kann eine erhöhte Skalium haben.
Manche Schwerden machen manchmal.
Elektrolyte müssen sich abnehmen.
Entzündungszeichen, Vitamin B12, B1, CRP,
schilddrüse, auch mit abnehmen.
Ich würde gerne eine detaillierte Laboruntersuchung durchführen.
Das heißt, reicht oder?
Vollkommen richtig, ja.
Soll man auch eine Likordiagnostik bezüglich Europaralyse?
Im Verlauf.
Ich würde sagen, eine neurologische Untersuchung.
Man sollte die Leitgeschwindigkeit messen.
Die Nervenleitgeschwindigkeit, dann eine EMG machen.
EMG.
Elektromyografie.
Neurologische Untersuchung.
Neurologisch auf jeden Fall.
Ich möchte das Gangbild des Patienten sehen.
Ganzbild.
Vollkommen richtig.
Neurologische Untersuchung.
Alle Hirn müssen untersucht werden.
Er hat gesagt, dass er eine Muskelschwäche hat.
Er kann auf den Zehnspitzen stehen.
Er kann auf einem Bein stehen.
Zum Beispiel so etwas in der Art.
Das muss natürlich auch die Reflexe und die Sensibilität kontrollieren.
Also eine neurologische Untersuchung.
Da ist alles mit dabei.
Stimmgabeltest zum Beispiel.
Kennen Sie das?
Stimmgabeltest.
Ob er ein Sensibilitätsverlust hat.
Ja, genau.
Und eine EMG.
EMG.
Und ein Gehirn MRT.
Kann man machen, richtig.
Definitiv.
Ja.
Also oft ist es so, dass Patienten die langjährigen Diabetes haben,
der nicht gut eingestellt ist,
natürlich eine neuropathie entwickeln.
Das ist so die Verdachtdiagnose.
Das Patient hat jetzt aber parallel auch Alkoholkonsum.
Man muss beides in Betracht ziehen.
Aber man muss natürlich auch gucken,
die anderen Felder, eine Gefäßwänderung.
Man muss also in mehreren Fachgebieten den Patient kontrollieren lassen.
Nicht nur neurologisch,
sondern angiologisch, radiologisch.
Also auch checken lassen.
Ja, ich werde...
Entprinologisch.
Dann auch die Schildprüße sein,
dass er eine Überfunktion hat.
Das wissen wir nicht.
Ja.
Und ja, ich...
Mein Batterie ist sehr niedrig.
Ich muss Entschuldigung.
Alles gut.
Ich würde gerne eine cardiologische Unterrichtung
mit einer Konzentration machen.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich werde gerne eine cardiologische Unterrichtung machen.
Ja, ich werde eine andere Unterrichtung machen.
Ich werde direkt eine Angiografie machen.
Ja.
Ich werde eine cardiologische Unterrichtung machen.
Ich werde eine Diabetes-Methyl-Altiniperelle
mit einer Diabetes-Methyl-Altiniperelle machen.
Ja.
Und Therapie müssen wir darüber sprechen?
Ja, also ich persönlich gehe
von einer Diabetes-Neuropathie aus.
Man muss also gucken,
dass man den Patienten gut Diabetes- logisch anbindet.
Vielleicht die Therapie optimiert.
Er hat nur Metformin.
Vielleicht braucht er ein SLGLT2-Hemmer.
Vielleicht auch andere Medikamente.
Wir wissen das noch nicht, dass wir in Blut sehen.
Aber wir müssen den Patienten empfehlen,
sein Alkoholkonsum zu reduzieren.
Weniger Alkohol zu trinken.
Und wir müssen die Blutwerte abwarten natürlich.
Und Diabeteschulung, eine Schulung,
können wir empfehlen?
Was hätten Sie vorher fragen können bei der Anamnese?
Wenn Sie fragen, wann war die letzte Kontrolle des HB1C?
Ja.
Wann waren die zuletzt beim Diabetologen?
Wann waren die zuletzt beim Hausarzt?
Entschuldigung, Hausarzt.
Das hätten Sie fragen können schon in der Anamnese.
Ja.
Das sind wichtige Fragen, die man in der Anamnese fragen sollte.
Wie war Ihr letzte HB1C?
Dann sagt der Patient, weiß ich nicht.
Aber der Patient hat die zuletzt kontrollieren lassen.
Er sagt letzte Woche, war gut oder war schlecht.
Oder war hoch.
Das sollten Sie fragen.
Immer die Frage, wann haben Sie das zuletzt kontrollieren lassen?
Ja.
Und gegebenenfalls müssen wir die Therapie neu verantworten.
Optimieren?
Optimieren oder eskalieren?
Eskalieren.
Und die Therapie für Diabetes.
Und einen Schmerzlinderung können wir Gabapentin verschreiben.
Ganz genau.
Weil das ja wahrscheinlich neuropatische Schmerzen sind.
Die Dramienangel, müssen wir perartochen.
Aurora.
Wenn ihr jetzt pepper commodities смотрите Thiamin geben.
Danach wo Sie queremos den Laser Motif abgeben.
Ja, und Gewichtsabnahme ist auch empfehlend investiert.
gefragt, ob er regelmäßig Wort macht.
Hatten wir auch fragen können, ob er Hobbys hat.
Ja, okay.
Und mir fest, nicht mehr.
Das kann natürlich auch alles infektiös sein.
Also, ich kann auch gleich eine infektiöse Erkrankung haben.
Also, ich muss leider dazu sagen, wir hätten auch fragen können,
er ist ja geschieden, ob er wechselnde Geschlechtspartner hat
oder so etwas.
Hatten wir auch fragen können.
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ein bisschen schwierig, glaube ich.
Ja.
Ja, schwierig.
Meine Fachbereich ist auch sehr...
Was sind Sie vom Fachbereich aus?
Microbiologie.
Seit zwölf Jahren habe ich keinen Kontakt mit den Patienten.